on duty as part of that commitment to a
free society as we are not just electing
a party leader but a prime minister the
country we love would expect us to
ensure that this process is rigorous
because we need a prime minister who
will deliver brexit and he will beat our
political opponents now those of us who
knock on doors week in and week out know
only too well that our political
opponents are far less committed to that
free society than we are supported by
the national convention offices I made
the case before the port party board
that the leadership campaign had to
reach every part of our United Kingdom
and that all members should have access
to at least one hustings there was no
disagreement on this and at this point
I'd like to therefore thank the party
chairman the right honourable Brandon
Lewis MP for his support I'd also like
to thank him more generally for his
support for the voluntary party you will
have noticed that we've got more
resources at our disposal than we've had
for many years and that is in large part
down to him and I'd also like to finally
thank the logistics team at CC HQ led by
Tom Skinner and the conference team led
by David Comerford who have done an
unbelievable job in very difficult
circumstances
you
to read it and please
very simple where we have campaign
managers we are doing better than in
areas where we do not but this is a
hugely expensive undertaking and we are
rather reliant on others to help us do
it at the moment so please can we be
true conservatives and help help
ourselves on this one ladies and
gentlemen that's it from me thank you
very much indeed Hannah enjoy your
evening and I hope your questions are
spot-on thanks very much I don't need to
remind you how crucial this whole
process is you're not just as
Conservative Party members electing a
new party leader you're also going to be
choosing the next prime minister of this
country as well now the candidates are
and taking it in turns and who goes
first in all of these hustings so
tonight first up is going to be Boris
Johnson and before we hear from the man
himself his team have put together a
short video for you yes you can if I get
in
[Music]
[Music]
that's the only way actually and you
know the only person that can do that a
lot of teachers tell me that they won't
believe on it they got their feel that
that the funding per pupil
[Music]
see big city was when I used to run it I
can tell you we got crime down by people
condiment another murder again I also
think we need to be supporting the
though the wealth graders in the
business sector because always you know
what Adam to the doctor during rest cut
some taxes
would you normally think of yourself as
a as a conservative voter would you say
no at our request would you consider
voting for me yes if there is one lesson
in that referendum of 2060 it is the too
many people feel left behind that
they're not able to take part fully in
the opportunities and success that's why
now is the time to unite our society and
unite our computer build the
infrastructure to invest in education to
improve our environment and to support
to lift every another and of course also
to make sure that we support our wealth
creators and the businesses that make
that investment possible
now's the time for us to believe in
ourselves and what we can do and that's
why I am standing to be leader of the
Conservative Party
[Music]
please welcome the first candidate line
to be the next prime minister
[Applause]
good it's fantastic views back here in
bubbles I wonder why we ever went away
from Mormons we should be absolutely to
be here but of course there are some
people will say ladies and gentleman my
friends old Pompey will say that these
are very dark and gloomy times for our
party in in a sense if you look at some
of the things that are going on there
entirely right we managed to score only
9% in the recent European elections I
never know in our party be down at that
level before we are on something like 17
18 19 20 percent in the polls or
apparently and we have sprouting like
two toadstools two puffballs feeding
saprophytic leon the decay and trust in
politics we have the the Liberal
Democrats and of course the brexit party
both taking strength taking votes from
our failure to get a great project done
and yet I say to you I say to you that
the hour is darkest before dawn and we
can turn this thing around and we can
recover and we can win and I'll tell you
what we need to do there are three
things that we need to do and the first
of them is what it is to get brexit done
to get brexit done to get rekt it over
the line by October the 31st and come
out
anybody anybody anybody who proposes any
further delay is simply going to end up
eroding trust in politics eroding
people's confidence in our democratic
institutions further and further
weakening our great Conservative Party
and our mission to lead this country and
it's simply won't work kick the can
again and we kick the bucket my friends
that is the sad reality but we can do so
much better because we can come out on
October the 31st we must come out and we
will and the way we do we get there's a
very good way of getting a great deal
you sort out the problems of the
Northern Irish backstop outside of the
current or withdrawal agreement you
disaggregate the elements of that
now-defunct withdrawal agreement and you
do the citizenship bit first give the
eave of 3.2 million EU nationals and
protections that we should have given
them years ago don't you think why not
absolutely give them that suspend the
money in a state of creative ambiguity
the 39 billion over the over the talks
until we get the answer that we want and
then and then use the the period of the
after we have come out after October the
31st to settle the problems of the Irish
border that all the technical fixes that
we know we can introduce to address
those issues whilst we negotiate the
free trade deal that is the logical way
to do it and that by the way is as an
approach that increasingly is carrying
support across our party uniting people
on all wings of the Conservative Party
and the way to get that deal of course
is to make sure that we prepare for No
Deal absolutely and and though people
there won't be people to say there will
be people who say that it's impossible
there will be people who say that the
planes went flying there web be clean
drinking water and there web be so there
might be enough milk solids and glucose
to make way to make Mars bars well I say
nonsense though the planes will fly
there will be drinking water whatever
happens on November the first in this
country and there will be Livie there
will be
solids and glucose and way for our Mars
bars where there's a will was away as I
as I repeatedly as I said and once we do
it once we've got out once we've got out
and while we're in the process of
negotiating that fantastic free trader
then we will be able to get on and do
what the people of this country want us
to do and that is bring the United
Kingdom together the whole UK the
awesome forcement this is one sentence
that sums up what I wanted to do as as
Prime Minister it is to unite our
country in the way that I was able to
unite London and I look back at those
eight years I began where the kind of
Tale of Two Cities people said that
London was deeply divided socially and
economically by the end we had brought
it together we had for the sixth poorest
boroughs anywhere in the UK by the end
through investment in transport
infrastructure by cutting crime by
building record numbers of homes we had
closed the opportunity gap we had none
of the poorest twenty boroughs anywhere
in the UK and that is what we're going
to do with our fantastic country we're
going to invest in infrastructure with a
lift up education spending around the
country and we're going to wanna close
the ridiculous digital divide that means
people across the country do not have
access to full fiber broadband in the
way that they should and we're going to
make sure that we have a programme of
full fiber broadband across the entire
UK at least eight years ahead of the
current ludicrously slow timetable and
with that will give us the chance that
will give us the chance to campaign for
modern conservatism what I've been and
what I mean by that is the balance the
symmetry between belief in the free
market and we haven't heard enough of it
in the last three years we haven't got
enough to talk up our basic than the
moral place the moral case the moral
case for conservatism because that's the
way to generate the income that will pay
for fantastic public services and
infrastructure
those are themselves essential for
business to invest and that is a very
very easy case to make and once we make
that case again with conviction and
clarity and power we will be able to do
the third and most important thing which
is to defeat Jeremy Corbyn
not only would not only put up taxes on
inheritance but on your financial
transaction tax he put up taxes on
pensions on income on Gardens my friends
here in Bournemouth he and at all to pay
for a ludicrous program of reen a tional
ization amounting to 300 billion pounds
he would be an economic and political
disaster for this country we cannot
allow it to happen are we going to allow
it to happen no we know we know we
certainly are not and I just say this in
conclusion I don't think it will happen
we have a we had yes things may look
gloomy now but we have a fantastic
opportunity with superhuman incompetence
the Labour Party actually managed to go
backwards in the recent council
elections the people of this country
aren't swallowing the semi marxist
claptrap of jeremy corbyn an 'test
and his london cabal and i would just
remind you in conclusion that the last
time i had to fight a representative of
that cabal of superannuated Marxists and
semi Marxist I was able in 2012 I have
far more in far more fertile in an
ingenious exponent by the way of that
ideology than Jeremy Corbyn I are my
team defeated Ken Livingstone when we
were 17 points behind in London we came
from behind to win we can do it we will
do it we must do it and with your help
we will thank you very much
so I didn't explain the format before
but and basically we're gonna have a ten
little so discussion now and then the
floor will be over to you first of all
Boris Johnson why do you want to be
Prime Minister because I have an
overwhelming sense of responsibility
right now - for the last three years
I've been frankly very frustrated to see
the direction of our argument about
BRICS it I've been depressed in a way to
see the way we've tended to run our
country down and not believed in
ourselves and one of the things that
being foreign secretary taught me was
that this country is loved and admired
and esteemed around the world and the
thing that they've so often said to me
friends in you know whether in India or
China or the girl from wherever they say
look you'll the United Kingdom your
Great Britain if you're going to do this
thing then do it believe in it and I
feel that incredibly strongly I want I
want I want to have a chance to take us
in what I think is overwhelming in the
right direction and get brexit down on
October 31st then deliver a
compassionate modern conservative agenda
lifelong ambition or sense of public
duty well this is my sister Rachel
notoriously said that I wanted to be
world king which is which is not a
quotation I recognized by the way but
you know I'd look I had all sorts of
ambitions in my life I wanted to be I
wanted to be a rock star at one stage
that didn't go too well but you know I
right now right now I think I've got to
I've got to try to do this I've really
got to try to do this because I can see
very clearly what needs to be done and I
have a good plan and a great team and
I'm very proud by the way of the range I
mentioned earlier we have we've got
large numbers of MPs backing me I don't
think anybody expected a year ago that
we'd have more than half the
parliamentary party behind me but that
that's where we are now policy then and
on immigration that seems to be what
you've been discussing today and the
Australian points-based
system we don't have it in this country
explain exactly how that would work what
it means obviously it's up to migration
Advisory Committee to look at the the
Australian experience and try to work
out what the the best way for but what
it means for me is that we continue to
it want to attract talent and when I was
mayor of London we we've benefited
massively from from you know motivated
people coming to London who with
whatever skill they might they might
have which this country often needs but
it should be done in a way that is - two
things first of all it should respond to
the needs of the sector concern so that
actually you know these people who come
when there is a job that they have on
offer they should come when there is a
need for someone of their skills to come
to this country and they should come in
a way finally that is democratically
controlled that's that that's that's the
most important thing and the problem
with the way the EU works is that
actually there was no control and people
could just come and and still can in a
in a company in treating this territory
as though it was part of which you know
which legally speaking it is part of a
gigantic 28-nation territory and that I
think did produce all sorts of it
produces did produce benefits but it
also produced lots of lots of strains
and lots of confusion this Australian
points-based system every system has its
faults what are the downsides of it I
you know the the downsides
might be I mean I haven't put it into
practice we haven't yet seen what the
downsides could be you know it's not
let's not listen with the upside for we
start looking for downsides about
bringing talent in for example what
about non workers come into this country
normally members okay well I mean family
members have as everybody knows already
very extensive rights of family reunion
which which are very clear on our
raishin system and you know wherever
they come from in the in the world as
for students
I'm very boom with University well the
great a great University
III pride to have a hoodie from
Bournemouth University which I go I go I
go jogging in I want I want to see
students taken out of the cab I think
that a higher education economy is one
of the glories of the UK's points-based
system apply to students and to family
members how would they be rated and a
points-based system I didn't you know
they would not it for my money be
included because what I'm what were what
we're looking at is you know family
members would have a right of reunion
that is understood according to you know
kindred and affinity and all and all the
rest of it and they're already
established procedures for deciding who
can who can come on the basis of a
family reunion as for students I think
that international students contribute
massively to the UK higher education
economy billions and billions of pounds
in in fees I make more than five billion
a year and the interesting question
actually and one that really deserves
thinking about is EU students in future
who are currently treated for for
revenue purposes as as UK nationals we
will have to consider obviously treating
them now as international students and
asking them to pay as well which will
bring in more money for our universities
okay I wouldn't want to brexit
and you told me yesterday that the
chance of a No Deal brexit was a million
to one
do you stand by those odds yes I do well
I mean you know there's not a bookies
but III do I think that I think that
there assert there are several there are
several things that have changed since
since March the 29th most importantly
the UK failed twice to come out with
really catastrophic consequences for
trust in politics and all of us MPs can
see that
and you're really seeing a change in the
mood in Westminster a realization that
unless we get this thing done unless we
act with maturity and dignity and work
together to get brexit over the line
there will be a very severe judgment of
history upon us and and not just a
judgment of history but there will be
democratic retribution upon both the
Conservative Party and and actually the
Labour Party as well and so that's why I
think we have a growing growing
opportunity to get this thing done with
with style come out on October the 31st
and then as I say use the use the next
period to negotiate an FTA and and get
on with all the looking through this
negotiating period then what
relationships did you perhaps Forge as
foreign secretary that you can then take
forward specific examples of
relationships you you forge that will
help you in this negotiating period
well I you you may not know this
Hannibal I I I spent many happy years in
in Brussels I know the system extremely
well and I'm a man if you know I was a
latterly a correspondent for The Daily
Telegraph but I with good relations with
my Irish counterpart Simon Kony who will
be very important in the in the
discussions I I certainly know most of
the key players have met them and talked
to them and just if you want evidence of
the kind of deal that we were able to do
with our with our European friends and
partners I mean I might single out
getting a lot of them to expel Russian
diplomats in support of the UK following
the poisonings in Salisbury and and you
know a lot of other friendly the French
the Germans many others came to our you
know or showed their solidarity with the
UK in a way that was really quite
extraordinary if you consider to kick
out a Russian spy means that you are
going to incur your own country is going
to incur retribution from computers and
but they did it to show solidarity we
us in the UK and and we organized in
contact with European negotiators I am
currently in contact with loads of
people around the world who are wishing
me well in the present context
specifically on our deal I'm not I have
not begun talking to my Monsieur Bonnier
who I know
Sabine Bay or anybody she's moved on
because I think most people in this
audience would think that was pretty
presumptuous I am I'm going to bide my
time but I of course I just think this
is an interesting point then it's
something underlying your your your
question we've gone a long way now by
going out and asking Brussels for for
this or that and and then being rebuffed
and feeling that we've got nowhere else
to go and I think it's time for a slight
change in our approach
I I think
I I'm I'm a bit I'm I'm a very ironic
kind of guy and and very very much in
favor of dialog and constant
conversation but in the end this is a
great great country and we've made an
extremely generous offer of 39 billion
are treating the treatment of the the EU
Nationals which I say we should we
should get done it's there's a very good
deal on the table waiting to be done by
our European friends hey what do you
think folks but I think a little bit
more resolve is called for and a little
bit more sense questions for you
as you'd expect and it's time to go over
to the audience now and the first up is
a Stephen Skinner who has a skillet not
the Stephen Skinner I used to know oh it
might be someone you know
Stephen thank you Stephen Skinner from
North Dorset nonetheless great he's
having seen all of the hustings and read
and heard all of the PR it's possible
that I will decide that one candidate is
best for the success of the party and
one is best for the prosperity of the
country which scenario should I vote for
and why well I think that the two
individuals are one of the same
I understand you I do because I
genuinely really Steven I think the the
problem that we've had and the reason
for so much business hesitation and the
reason for so much confusion and
indecision is that it is they are
reflecting and responding to political
indecision and our unwillingness over
the last three years to decide some
fundamental questions about what we're
going to do to make sense of brexit
particularly how to come out of the
customers union and how to achieve
regulatory divergence actually to take
advantage of the freedoms that the
brexit will give us and I think that
will not only once they have some
clarity once the business community has
some clarity I think that will trigger a
great sense of confidence and certainty
about the way to proceed because believe
me there's no problem the British
business caught in the end solve an
address and there are plenty of
opportunities that brexit will will
provide and we will we will certainly as
a government be willing to help I also
think that paradoxically that clarity
will be warmly welcomed across the
channel where for three years they'd
been rather baffled by what we really
want and when they have a clear answer
about what we really want I think the
mood will lighten and we will be able to
take things forward and just following
up on that then it if it was the choice
between party or country yes or if it
was the choice but you can just ignore
that if it was the choice between party
or country the unity of which one should
come first again I think the two the two
it's a false choice because I think the
two things go hand in hand
an acceptable that's a very good
question
I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding about this actually I
think that a really good brexit will
help to cement the Union because there
are all sorts of ways in which post
breaks it will be able to intensify the
Union I'll also point out that the
Scottish Nationalist Party well
effectively had their guns spiked
because once we make a great successor
of brexit they will have to argue
the people of Scotland that they want to
rejoin the EU join the euro join the
Schengen area submit Scotland to every
type of EU regulation and and lose
control which that will they they will
have just gained lose control of
Scottish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
could go back into the DA's office
[Music]
[Music]
you want to take the bathroom now
[Music]
this isn't his car this is fan
[Music]
[Music]
what you doing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
No
No
[Music]
oh you got really to super-sharp really
playful
they might be like I'm putting the
picture
[Music]
[ __ ] picture
refresh
why
hey do you want this and I'll take this
to the back door
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are y'all here for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I would
he's gone he went out the garage
makes total sense
[Music]
you
calm and forth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
we all take steps to increase education
funding fund and check to reflect the
the needs of schools around the country
at the moment at the moment yeah I look
I of course there is London has
particular expenses we all understand
that the extra costs on teachers and
schools in London but a moment the per
capita per kid payment is about two six
thousand eight hundred pounds or up at
that level in some places in parts of
rural Britain it's down to four thousand
two hundred or perhaps even even though
you know these are these are big
discrepancies it makes a big difference
to schools to to teachers to the to the
lives and hopes of the kids so come on
we've got a we've got a level up and and
that is you know that is the core
message about what I want to to
accomplish if I'm lucky enough to be
elected it's about leveling up this
country Breck's it was it was a was a
partly about democracy it was partly
about immigration but it was also you
know very largely about democracy and
and substantially about immigration but
it was also about a sense in too many
places around the UK that they were left
behind and that they were unloved that
they weren't sufficiently invested in
and are not part of the gigantic success
of London and the South East which are
the most productive regions in the whole
of Europe knockout success in that area
but you know literally 500 times around
the UK that could be doing so much
better and we've got to lift up the
whole country there are ways of doing it
with infrastructure with education with
technology like broadband we should get
on and do it and that's what I want to
do can you make a commitment on
education funding yes I think I already
have I want I want I want to I want to
raise education funding it will cost
billions but it has got to be done
well it'll be it'll be it'll be it'll be
around five billion is what I think
we'll need to spend but it has to be
done okay around five billion Chris
Russell has a question good evening
Chris Russell Winchester conservative
Association I've been musing recently
about what we'd call a collective now
for a conservative party members and I
came to the conclusion it would be a
division we we have a very fractured
party
how would you heal that fracture I agree
with you the sad thing is that what you
say is is true but I think that the
reason we feel divided is because there
has been such a lack of decision and
such lack of clarity and you know we all
know the psychologic
when when people feel that they don't
there's an argument about which way to
go there of course there's there's
there's no clarity and and people
wrangle and that is actually
paradoxically got worse since the
referendum not better and what we need
now is a clearer charting of the way
ahead and above all to come out of the
EU on October the 31st and if you do
that if you do that which I take that
the what will happen of course is that
both these puffball parties that I've
described I don't wish to be
disrespectful to them or to there
anybody who supports them well what I
mean is that they're they've sprouted
saprophytic Lee on the on the on the
decay of trust and there they were they
arisen because people feel that they
can't trust us or labor to get brexit
done and they certainly can they
certainly can I think it's I think it's
absolutely crucial and to get back to
your point if we get it done in the way
I want and we will
then what will actually happen is that
far from people feeling more divided the
object of controversy will be removed
and we as a party will be able to get on
with the things that basically unite us
and the great project on which we are
united is I think taking this country
forward with that very very simple
vision of modern conservatives in which
we trust in the market trust in
enterprise support business but because
we know that that's the way to pay for
fantastic public services and so many
other wonderful civilized things and and
that is a very very easy message to sell
but we haven't been selling it for the
last three years so let's get back to
that basic conservative tune it's a
great song
and with that your time is out course
Johnson thank you very much indeed thank
you
to hear from the other candidate running
to be the leader of this party and of
the country as well before Jeremy Hunt
comes out to speak to you we're going to
hear from his campaign team as well a
video
the most striking quality about Jeremy
Hunt was his unwavering commitment to
get results
I think perhaps part of that is to do
with his background in business no
matter what the obstacles were he was
prepared to push through them he wanted
to get results I've seen him deliver on
the things that matter most to the
British people he has credibility from
all sides I trust him on brexit I'm new
in Jeremy for 40 years about 25 of those
years we've worked together
setting up various businesses those
early days were absolutely about his
determination and grit would never give
up well I first met Jeremy I realised
there was a man who actually was
committed to making a difference in 2008
I lost my baby son Joshua as a
consequence of serious failures in his
care during my campaigns and uncover the
truth about
to be heard Jeremy really listed the
treats of me mr. breathing dad rather
than the troublemaker I knew Jeremy was
incredibly kind daughter behind the
[Music]
[Music]
underestimate Jeremy because he comes
across being such a polite and generous
an item person and he is but when we're
hearing of awarding the EU not to
mistake British politeness with British
weakness and I think that just about
sums it up I was presently speaking
about London Olympics and I thought you
know we couldn't mess this up I'm
talking to Jeremy in the bill that I
said no you know we're a great country
we can do this we have the right mindset
the delivery was outstanding
he also had a settlement have fun I know
was very involved in getting that
balance right
he believes in Britain as a force for
good in the world
he shows strong values at the FCO and
consistently through judgments and
negotiations toughing it out when things
get really difficult keeping going
having a vision those are the skills
that we need in the primers visit
unifier is somebody who can reach out to
different groups of people
my daddy was talking dance party should
be about making a difference in ordinary
people's lives under a very huge
difference in to our lives we gave to
hope and that for me was the main thing
really gave us hope that's a very valid
object for the other man who is vying to
be the next prime minister of this
country the current foreign secretary oh
I've got some volume on good job I've
got a booming voice and Jeremy Hunt
welcome
friends good evening this has been an
amazing campaign I've had fish and chips
in Aberdeen a Balti in Birmingham and
ice cream on the front here the worst
photo op you could imagine - free
haircuts I've still got some hair and
there's something familiar about here
haven't we been here before isn't it
time we bought our Party conference back
to Bournemouth now the nice thing about
being the underdog is that for the first
time in my life the Internet is actually
being quite kind to me and they kindly
ran a competition for what my campaign
slogan should be so I had hashtag take a
punt on hunt
I had hashtag J's as the Beza and I had
hashtag hunt emic hunt face now be very
careful how you say that at home because
we are the party of the family but
friends we are in a very serious
situation if we get this wrong we risk
no Conservative government no brexit no
Conservative Party even but if we get it
right we can deliver brexit unleash the
potential of our extraordinary country
and send Corbin packing
now we've had a lot of discussion in
these brexit debates about how but not
enough discussion about who who is the
Prime Minister we trust to go to
Brussels and sort this out and if you
choose me I'll be the first Prime
Minister who has a background as an
entrepreneur now who here has set up
their own business just put up your hand
if you've set up that is the
Conservative Party the party of business
and what do we do
entrepreneurs we negotiate that is what
you do every single day with your
customers with your suppliers with your
employees and what's the first rule of
negotiation you have to be prepared to
walk away and what's the second rule
you've got to figure out what the other
people are going to do and this is where
we have a challenge because there are
some people in Parliament and I totally
deplore this but there are some people
in Parliament who have voted and will
vote to take no deal off the table and
we have got to recognize we can't wish
that reality away the quickest way to
get out of the european union is to
negotiate a deal that can get through
Parliament and that is what this
entrepreneur this negotiator is going to
do for our party and for our country
because we are one of the oldest
democracies in the world and in this
country we do what the people tell us
and we're going to deliver brexit
and when we do what incredible
excitement awaits as someone who set up
their own business I am just champing in
a bit
to turn us into the fastest-growing most
high-tech greenest most dynamic Pro
enterprise economy in Europe in we've
got the top universities in Europe some
of the top ones in the world
we've got more tech entrepreneurs we
could be the world's next Silicon Valley
here in this part of the world you've
got the fiber-optic program in
Bournemouth superfast Dorset huge growth
in tech jobs you know what this is all
about and I'm going to take a giant step
towards that by cutting corporation tax
to twelve and a half percent Irish
levels and we are going to put an
economic jumbo jet on Europe's doorstep
so that when it comes to those trade
negotiations they need us every bit as
much as we need them
and I'm also the foreign secretary who
wants Britain to walk tall in the world
my dad was in the Navy we followed him
all around the country from from Devon
to Portsmouth to Surrey to Scotland and
thanks to his generation and their
service we won the Cold War they never
took peace for granted and nor will I
and that's why I've said I'll increase
defense spending to beyond two percent
of GDP not just to deal with aggression
from countries like Russia but also
because at the point of brexit I want
the world to know that Britain one of
the few countries that stands up for
democratic values and the security
needed to underpin it Britain is here
Britain is back and Britain's voice is
going to be strong in the world
I'd be the first Prime Minister who's
been responsible for our NHS and I
always think that we should have a
social mission not just an economic
mission and I was proud to be
responsible for some fantastic hospitals
in this area Southampton Bournemouth
pull many great hospitals but I want our
next social mission to be the social
care system in this part of the world
the proportion of over 80s is 50% higher
than the national average of course
that's no one in the audience tonight
none of you look a day over 40 except
for Steve Bryan who's working too hard
in Winchester but Social Care is
important because as conservatives we
want every single older person in our
country to be treated with dignity and
respect and we also care about younger
people and I want us to be the
Conservative government that abolishes
illiteracy and make sure that every
young person leaves school with the
rigorous qualification so they can get a
decently paid job and finally politics
is about winning elections and if you
choose me be the first Prime Minister in
half a century who's won a marginal seat
I know what it's like to knock on every
single door need every single vote I'm
looking at every single vote right now
and you know it's hard work but I make
you two promises number one by the time
we go into a general election if I'm
Prime Minister we will get more young
people voting conservative because we
can't be the party of aspiration and
that's the most aspirational people are
voting for
and my second and final promise is this
I will not provoke a general election
until we've left the European Union we
can't ask for another mandate from the
British people until we've delivered the
mandate that we were given last time
forget that ignore that and we ignore
the lessons of Peterborough where labor
crept through the middle we ignore the
crocodile lurking under the water of
British politics a Labour Party led by
the most ruthless dangerous anti Western
anti British hard left cabal ever in its
history under Jeremy Corbyn the biggest
danger to our country we won't let them
take over and I'm telling you this right
now faced with that hard left populist
Jeremy Corbyn sure we could choose our
own populist but we can do better we can
choose our own Jeremy hey Jeremy
hey Jeremy who's going to win the
argument for enterprise aspiration for
true social justice not so much for
those of us here this evening most of us
have done okay but social justice for
the young people desperate for a
decently paid job the families
desperately saving up to buy a home for
older people so keen just to live out
their time in dignity those other people
the Conservative Party is for those are
the people who must fight for we've got
a deliverer brexit unleash the
incredible potential of our amazing
country let me show you how thank you
very much
take a sip or two good and why do you
want to be Prime Minister because I want
to change our country I think we have
and I was always brought up to believe
that we have the most incredible country
anywhere I think you win the lottery
ticket of life if you're born a British
citizen because we are a country that is
incredibly successful we fight for our
values but we're also a compassionate
country as well but I look at our
country today and I think there's so
much more that we can do so much more
with our economy so much more to give
ourselves the best health care and
education systems in the world and so
much more as a Conservative Party that
we can do to bring our country together
after such a difficult and divisive here
and that's what I want to do are you
concerned about threats that it could be
the shortest tenure in history well if
we get this wrong it will be and we have
got the biggest constitutional crisis in
living memory and that is because MPs
like me made a promise to the people
that we would deliver the outcome of the
referendum whatever it was and we failed
and that's a shaken people's confidence
in our democracy so it is a very
challenging period and we need a prime
minister who is going to pick his way
through that get us to the other side
deliver the brexit that people voted for
and bring the country together
if you fail on brexit though to deliver
the brexit that you say that you that
you want or that No Deal is perhaps far
more disastrous to this country than has
been then you've previously predicted
would you fall on your sword and resign
of course I mean no Prime Minister is
going to last any time at all if they
don't deliver brexit and deliver it very
quickly that is that is the reality of
British politics that's not about Jeremy
Hunt that's about anyone who does that
job but you know No Deal is is for me
a last choice but it's one I would
always keep on the table and if we
get to October and there is no prospect
of a deal that we can get through
Parliament and no deal is on the table
as I sincerely hope it would be then I'm
absolutely clear I will leave because
that is what we promised and it won't be
easy and it will be bumpy but we've been
through worse and we would make a
success of it but we have to fulfill
that solemn promise to the British
people because when I go around the
world as foreign secretary I meet so
many countries they have this respect
for Britain actually a whole lot more
respect for us than we sometimes have
for ourselves and what they respect is
that we are a democracy you know
extraordinary things like changing our
prime minister in 1944 which seems so
strange when you look back on it that we
would do that but that told the world
that this was a democracy and that's an
incredibly precious thing and that's why
we have to deliver brexit and deliver it
soon your deal for brexit what's in it
well I don't think there's a big
difference actually between me and Boris
in that respect I think we both want to
change the deal that we have on the
table to remove the backstop so that it
can't trap us in the customs union
forever I think we both want a
technology solution my approach as a
negotiator to getting there is to learn
the lessons of what went wrong last time
last time the EU stopped negotiating
with us because very sadly they didn't
believe that the British government
could deliver Parliament they said
what's the point of making any more
concessions because we don't think
you'll get it through Parliament so I'll
put on my negotiating team the dup the
ERG who are the brexit purists in our
party Scottish Conservatives Welsh
conservatives to show the EU that any
deal that we propose is one that we can
get through Parliament and I think
that's the first very important step
you've said in the past that the the
political consequences of no brexit
would far outweigh the economic
consequences of no
EAL what about the political
consequences of No Deal if it started to
threaten the United Kingdom and the
Union well I think there is a risk if we
you know if we had to deal with a No
Deal situation I think Nicola Sturgeon
would make absolute hay with that she
she wants to persuade people in Scotland
that it's badly governed from
Westminster so she would use that so we
would have to do everything we could to
make sure she didn't exploit that and
let's be clear as Prime Minister I will
never ever allow our precious union to
be broken up so that is going to be a
challenge but I don't think it's
insurmountable and in the end more than
a million people in Scotland voted to
leave the European Union and we have to
be true to their wishes as well and I
think we can make no deal work but I
would do it with a heavy heart because
of the risks as you say both to the
Union and to businesses on foreign
policy your foreign secretary right now
what relationships have you forged as in
your current role that you think set you
in good stead when it comes to brexit
negotiation so specific relationships
with EU counterparts well I think I have
good relationships with all my
counterparts but they're very direct
relationships you know I tell them how
it is I told them six months ago lots of
them that that I thought that they were
driving a bargain with the UK that was
going to be too hard to get through
Parliament and I I said I think you've
got to be very very careful going down
this route because you could end up with
a situation that's very bad for the EU
as well as bad for the UK so I don't
think it it helps to be friendly but a
friend tells you things as they are
outside of the outside of Europe then
this morning the your Japanese
counterparts and Japanese government's
urged the UK to avoid a no deal
situation yes I have this discussion
with the Japanese many times and they
understandably don't want no deal
because they've got very big investments
in this country particularly in the
in the car industry but what I say to
them is that you know in the second
world war we fought for democracy across
the world including in Japan and they
have to understand that in the end that
is something that this country will
always fight for and we made a decision
to leave the European Union and
democratic decision and we are going to
honor that decision and so you know if
anyone thinks that we would cancel
brexit because of a fear of No Deal they
totally misunderstand Britain but that
doesn't mean it's our first choice we
understand their concerns and that's why
I think we need to recognize that you
know the best outcome is to try and
negotiate that deal and that's what I
think I can do I want to ask you about
your spending commitments so far as well
we talked about cutting corporation tax
increasing the threshold and national
insurance contributions reducing
interest rates and student loans as well
defense spending if you're now making a
commitment on entrepreneurs young
entrepreneurs well Mike so my worry I'm
a supporter of our changes to Jewish
movies because they've given us some of
the best funded and best universities in
the world but I can't when I knock on
doors in my constituency justify 6%
interest rates on tuition fees it's not
fair and the risk we have with having
interest rates that high is that will
end up discrediting the whole system so
I do think if we want to attract younger
people we have to recognize their
legitimate concerns and I also think I
set up my own business in my 20s and
that was a period when we didn't have
tuition fees and I worry we want our
brightest graduates to go out and do
what Bill Gates did and Mark Zuckerberg
did and set up these amazing technology
companies but some of those people might
be put off doing that with debts of 50
60 grand so I want to say to them and
this will only apply to a small number
of people I want to say to them look if
you go out and you set up a successful
business and you employ people
then we'll cancel your tuition fees
because they've done a great thing for
the country they've created wealth for
us they've created jobs and we should
support them and encourage them to do it
[Applause]
perhaps student straight out of
university employing their mates for a
couple of years and then and they get
their debt way you know if well no my
specific proposal is that you have to
employ ten people full-time for five
years now if we're flooded with people
doing that that's brilliant for our
country we should encourage that be
fantastic with all of the spending
announcements that you've made so far it
would cost in the region of 37 to 68
billion pounds where does that money
come from well that's because they have
misinterpreted what I've said so the tax
cut that I have committed to is a
cutting corporation tax to twelve and a
half percent that is expensive they
think it costs 12 billion I think it
costs nine billion but if they're right
the truth is with that tax cut you get
about half that money back fairly
quickly because you get more investment
people's profits go up people pay employ
more people more salaries of pay more
dividends are paid so it's actually one
of the most efficient tax cuts but the
purpose of that tax cut is to increase
our growth rate at the moment were
growing at one-and-a-half percent if we
could boost that to three percent which
is the growth rate they have in America
that would be an extra 20 billion pounds
a year for public services or tax cuts
so our focus in terms of where we spend
our money has to be on growing our
economy so that we can do all the things
we want to do later we spoke yesterday
about your time as health secretary and
and then you said that the when it came
to the junior doctors brow but the
policy you had was right but you
communicated it badly have you learnt
enough and do you think it's enough to
convince junior doctors now to support
you well I'll never forget my first
month as health secretary
and I had to deal with the crisis in mid
staffs
and the Department of Health advised me
not to meet the families from mid staffs
but I ignored that advice and I met a
woman whose mother died a really
horrible death effectively she was
starved to death she looked me in the
eye and she said Jeremy you could be the
one that changes this and I never forgot
that and by the end of my time I had a
few more gray hairs but six years on we
had 2.7 million more patients using good
or outstanding hospitals every year and
I was proud of that and I did have some
battles and of course with the benefit
of hindsight I could have communicated
my vision better and I think junior
doctors are fantastic people they are
the future of the NHS and and I I
support them and I was sad that we had
that battle but do I regret that focus
on patient safety that focus on raising
standards no because that's what
conservatives believe in we say yes the
money matters but it's not just about
the money it's about the standards we
deliver and that's something only
conservatives understand
and so to kick things off Christine born
has a question Christine Wimborne
Minster in Dorset what are the three
most important pieces of legislation
that you as Prime Minister will bring
forward in the first Queen's speech of
the new session of Parliament thank you
very important question and so let me
tell you what there be first of all
there would be a No Deal bill to make
sure that we have all the planning in
place all the preparations in place so
we can fully prepare this country for a
No Deal brexit if that's what we have to
do and I'm talking about much much
bigger things than we've been able to do
in the past one of the things if you
have customs checks between countries is
that instead of roll-on/roll-off lorries
going between US and the EU you have to
move to containers so we're gonna have
to have a big expansion of our container
capacity imports like Tovar things like
that we need to spend money on quickly
in order to strengthen our hand in the
negotiations second bill would be a
budget because I want those business tax
cuts to happen right away because the
best preparation we can have for a No
Deal brexit is to fire up our economy
and to put money in the pockets of
businesses so they can be strong and
resilient with all the the changes that
lie ahead and then what's the third
thing I'd really like to do well I said
that I would like to be the Conservative
government that abolished is illiteracy
and nearly a quarter of our children
leave primary school not able to read
and write to be appropriate levels and I
would like to pass the legislation
that's necessary to require schools
wherever they are to make sure that
every single young person leaves
properly able to read or write
Maker's spending commitment on education
as well within that legislation yes but
I would do it in the way I did for the
NHS because changing deep-rooted
problems like illiteracy doesn't happen
overnight it's it's not by the way about
the hard work or commitment of teachers
it's about you know being very rigorous
in particularly in the schools that
don't get good Ofsted ratings but what I
would do is I would say look I'm
prepared to put money on the table but
you need to show me the reforms that
you're prepared to do to make sure that
every single young person leaves
education with those rigorous
qualifications that's going to set them
up for life number you put 15 billion on
defense what about on education well on
education I think I want to talk to them
I by the way we didn't answer your
earlier question about how what my
fiscal rule will be all my commitments
are funded through a pledge that I will
keep reducing debt as a proportion of
GDP over the economic cycles so we won't
be building up debt for future
generations we actually have now about
26 billion pounds of headroom a year
which is why we can afford some of these
commitments the commitment I will make
on education is that if and that can be
afforded within these numbers that I
will restore per pupil funding to 2015
levels if I can get that commitment to
reform the next question is from Toni
Toni Devenish good evening Jeremy
getting on with the domestic agenda is
key to will you implement a policy with
the residence of Margaret Thatcher's
council house sales to win back the
domestic agenda and here's one example
abolish stamp duty for homes under 1
million pounds
thanks Tony a very important question
and this is actually a matter of trust
for young people because they look at
our generation and they say you you
bought a house maybe in your 20s or 30s
it's appreciated in value a lot which is
great for you but it is much much harder
for us now to get off foot on the
housing ladder Margaret Thatcher got one
and a half million council tenants onto
the housing ladder through her right to
buy scheme I have an equally ambitious
scheme called right to own which will
help one and a half million young people
get on the housing ladder people who
can't afford a mortgage or a deposit and
the way we'll do that is by gifting
people land that already has planning
permission so that the increase in the
value of the land isn't something that
goes to developers but it actually goes
to the young person who can't afford to
get onto the housing ladder we'll be
publishing details of those plans in the
next few days but that is a central part
of my mission to get more young people
to support our party because that is so
important for our future properties
under a million well I you know I would
love to do reductions in stamp duty but
but Tony this scheme is also going to
cost money and I want to focus on
getting one and a half million younger
people onto the housing ladder and I
think this scheme could do that the next
question comes from Lorna McCulloch from
Oxford and what are your plans to
alleviate the financial burden on
students going to university but do not
wish to come out with 50 at least 50,000
pounds of debt the interest charged at
3% of RPI bears no relationship to the
cost of borrowing incurred by the
government well although we've talked a
bit a little bit about this before but
um what is crazy about our system at the
moment
is that only half student debt actually
gets repaid and the reason why the
interest rate is so high at 6% is
because the treasurer is saying they
want the whole scheme to be self funding
so they ramped up the interest rate for
the people who can pay back their
tuition fees but of course that means
more and more people end up not being
able to pay back their tuition fees and
what feels so unfair to students is that
that 6% interest rate is actually
ramping up while they're at university
even when they're not working and it
just feels unfair and I think we have
made good reforms in my generation we
didn't have tuition fees but only 11% of
school leavers went to university now
it's 50% that is much fairer but we need
to have a fair system and so before
Hannah asked me how much this is going
to cost to reduce tuition fees interest
rates to around the level of inflation
would cost about 1.3 billion pounds a
year that is a lot of money but I tell
you if we don't do something like that
jeremy corbyn's going to come along at
the next election and promise to scrap a
lot of it and we're going to lose every
single young person to him and maybe the
election as well
Christine Paige has a question Christine
good evening mr. hunt in view of the
complete necessity of completing brexit
by the 31st of october as a member I
would be baffled that she would not
harness the support of all politicians
including Nigel Faraj would you include
mr. Faraj in negotiations no Christine
the reason for that very direct answer
is that Nigel Faraj doesn't want a deal
he wants a WTO brexit straight away and
whilst I would be prepared to do that if
there was no other alternative and I'm
absolutely clear about that
I think it would be much better for our
businesses and much better for our union
if we could get a deal and I haven't
given up on that I think we should be
optimistic and positive when I talk to
European leaders they know this is
difficult but they don't want a No Deal
brexit they want to find a way through
this and I think if we take the right
approach we can get that I don't say
it's easy but it's not impossible and we
conserve this as the more difficult
things in the past and we can certainly
do this
Nigel Faraj because Boris Johnson was
also asked this yesterday and he said
the same as you he said no he wouldn't
include him in any negotiations going
forward and he has though garnered so
much enthusiasm through the brexit party
throughout the country and how will you
as Prime Minister and as leader of the
Conservative Party then counter that
threat from the brexit party you know
there is only one way to deal with a
brexit party and that is to brexit
that's what we've got to do
and then we'll deal with them everyone
available well we have got incredible
talent in our Conservative Party and we
don't need to to deal with people who
don't even have any MPs in Parliament
well what I'll say is that as a
Conservative Party if we're going to do
this we have got to learn the values of
unity you know in the 1980s we had that
great reforming government of Margaret
Thatcher but you had around the cabinet
table people like Geoffrey Howe a Norman
Tebbit totally different people around
the same cabinet table in the 1990s you
had John redwood and Ken Clark around
the same cabinet table and that's the
genius of our party we have the the
radical reformers who remind us that we
have to be bold if we're going to be a
great country and the one nation
conservatives who remind us that we have
to be compassionate and reach out to the
center ground and we need both those
traditions in our party and if we come
together we can deliver brexit and
that's what we have to do in the next
few months the makeup of your cabinet as
well in terms of the balance between
possible remain votes in the past and
remain as and leaders do you know Hannah
I think it's so dangerous to label
people as remain as brexit ears brexit
ears remain errs you know we are all
Democrats
I vote it remained like millions of
remainders around the country I want to
get on and deliver brexit and that's the
way we're going to deliver it if we come
together in this big democratic mission
that's what I want us to do
the next question from Jake
so you weren't you're not you your name
wasn't on the list but I'll yell your
questions so I profoundly disagree with
my cabinet colleagues who with my
colleagues in the Conservative Party
actually who have voted to rule out no
deal in my cabinet we will be voting to
keep no deal on the table that will be
government policy cabinet policy and I
would expect all colleagues to follow
the line on that because that will
strengthen our hand in the negotiations
[Applause]
good evening David sidwich policing
crime Commissioner candidate for Dorset
thank you will you give more core
funding to the police so that the
manpower reflects the demand and allows
them to address not only serious crime
but the distressing antisocial behavior
or if you like quality of life crime
which affects people more on a day to
day basis well first of all very best of
luck to you in the PCC elections and
thank you for the question
I was part of the government that came
into power the cabinet that came in in
May 2010 and we were facing the biggest
financial crisis that we'd had in
peacetime and we made some decisions to
put the economy back on its feet and
what Jeremy Corbyn likes to label
austerity they were very very difficult
cuts in spending and I think we were
right to do that because the result of
that is that the economy has grown jobs
have been created I was able to secure
that big increase in funding for the NHS
but I think it's true also that in one
or two areas we can see with the benefit
of high
site that some of those cuts went a bit
too far and the two areas that I would
single out are the social care system
where I do think that councils are
finding it very hard to deliver the
standard of care that we as
conservatives would expect and also
police numbers where there's a delayed
impact so crime continues to fall for a
while when you cut police numbers but
after a while it catches up with you so
those are two areas without making an
explicit spending pledge that I would
commit to look at as Prime Minister
stopped and searched expanding stopping
search committed to yes I agree with
Boris on that I agree with Sajid Javid
on that stop and search is a very
important power for the police of course
it has to be used sensitively but they
do have to have the ability to stop
someone that they suspect might be
carrying knives committing a crime
within the law and so I support them
being able to do what they need to do ok
the next question comes from Jack either
Jack Bolton or Jackie's from Bolton
Winchester actually
good evening I'd like to ask you if you
yourself could make the difficult
decision that Jeremy Corbyn cannot
namely would you use our nuclear
deterrent in extreme circumstances well
Jack from Winchester my my dad was in
the Navy
and in his last job in the Navy he
actually had responsibility for the
nuclear deterrent and this was something
that we thought about very hard in our
family and if you have a deterrent that
you say you're never going to use it's
not a deterrent and that is why it would
be completely wrong for any Prime
Minister to say that they wouldn't ever
use a nuclear deterrent the lesson from
the success of the nuclear deterrent is
that you have to be strong to be safe
and that is what we did in the Cold War
and I think we need to recognize now
that the world is becoming again
increasingly unstable when you look at
what's happening in the Middle East when
you look at what's happening in Russia
when you look at a China that is
becoming more autocratic and it's been
Britain's historic role to be one of the
very few countries that doesn't just
speak out for democratic values but also
understands you've got to have hard
power behind that to have credibility
and that at the point of Breck's in the
start of this moment in our exciting new
moment our history I want us to do that
now too
[Applause]
good evening Dorsett the National Health
Service has taken on the status of a
national religion and is often said to
be beyond sensible management and reform
based by those inside it working for it
and by those outside it do you agree
with this and do you think that the NHS
should continue to try to do everything
for everybody regardless of personal
responsibility
well the NHS can't do everything but it
can do a lot and I would like it to
continue to do everything that it does
for everyone regardless of ability to
pay because I was brought up to believe
that one of the best things about this
country is that if you get sick you
don't have to worry about paying medical
bills and I think that we should be
proud that we were I think the sixth
country in the world - you need to
introduce universal healthcare coverage
the Kiwis were actually the very first
country to do it but we were one of the
very first and since then it's become
it's been adopted by nearly every
country everywhere in the world but we
also have to recognize that personal
responsibility is important how people
look after themselves is important and
we need to encourage people to do that
because as Steve Brian the Winchester MP
second time I've mentioned Steve this
evening but he was a brilliant Minister
for public health for many years
encouraging people to live healthier
lifestyles that personal responsibility
is important but as conservatives what I
can say is that I look at the NHS and I
compare it to other healthcare systems
around the world and we've got our
problems we've got our challenges but
other countries have just as many
challenges and the challenges that we're
really facing out because of an ageing
population
in countries like America the challenge
is spiraling insurance bills we're
actually one of the most efficient
healthcare systems in the world as
conservatives though we understand what
you understand that isn't just about
money it's about reform it's about
standards and my ambition for the NHS I
would like us in a decade's time to have
the best cancer survival rates in Europe
because it still frustrates me that with
all the brilliant doctors and nurses
that we have in the NHS we don't get
those cancer survival rates that we
could I know we can do that and that's
something I would like to press the NHS
to do the last point of part of Tim's
question then was should the NHS do
everything that it possibly can
regardless of personal responsibility
what role do you think personal
responsibility has been regards to
health service well I I don't think we
should start rationing services I don't
think that's what the the British people
want but that doesn't mean we can't do
an awful lot to encourage people to live
responsibly when I was health secretary
we published a huge programme to tackle
childhood obesity and I think we said
we're gonna a bullet we're gonna have
childhood obesity rates in a decade we
put the programme in place to do that
but actually to do that what we realized
is we need the help of parents this is
not something that we can do on our own
so there's a big role for personal
responsibility but if you are clear
about how you go about this people want
to take care of their own health they
really do but we have to make sure we're
getting those messages on more questions
then George Smith has a question George
with the recent shortfalls of rail
transportation as well as the national
rail saying that they want to change
operations how would you improve inter
and intra city travel to help boost
economic mobility well I'm gonna say
something that isn't particularly
popular with some conservative members
living in some parts of the country but
I will deliver a CH
to now I saw a plums down over there
about eight rows back and and I can
completely understand why if it's going
through the middle of your your
beautiful constituency you might not
want it but let me tell you why um at
the point of brexit we've got to show
the world confidence and hs2 is our
biggest infrastructure project I lived
in Japan for two years they launched
their first high-speed rail between
Tokyo and Osaka in 1964 two years before
I was born
we're going to be doing ours in 2026
which is a little bit late it'll be
better than the Japanese one when we
launched it but nonetheless it's taken a
long time and if we want to be a modern
economy a powerhouse that creates wealth
for all our public services like the NHS
that we've just been talking about then
we have to do that and we also have to
show the country that we are committed
to spreading wealth throughout the
country our heartlands are London and
the South East but we won't win any
elections without winning marginals in
the Midlands and the north and projects
like hs2 are seen in those areas are
symbols of our commitment to the whole
country and that's why I back it angle
angel is angel
what are your plans for the diversifying
higher education in order to provide
more options for college students who
are leaving college but don't
necessarily want to progress to
university or